we need to go to stormont at the moment
and bring in edwin putz
uh the dup leader uh to here he's
forming a new cabinet
and gary middleton be our junior
minister
and they will carry on the excellent
work that has been done in the
ministerial office by ireland foster
and by gordon lyons i'm delighted to
have them
on our team the changes will take place
on monday
so this is a nice moment in advance of
what takes place
next monday in terms of all of the
changes that are happening
so i hand over to paul
okay thank you good afternoon can i
first thank edwin and paula and
my colleagues for their support and
taking up this
very important role there's a huge
responsibility that comes with this
position
particularly in serving the people of
northern ireland as we come through
the covered pandemic the recovery that's
needed in our economy within our
education system
and meeting the needs of the people we
have a huge task when it comes to
tackling our waiting lists
and we need to get to work so what we
now need is an effective
transition that needs to take place next
week
so that we have that smooth delivery of
governance
and that is something that i look
forward to doing
i want to pay tribute to those of whom
i'm following
dr paisley who founded this party as
first minister
peter robinson and of course arlene
foster
these are giants of unionism giants
within our party
and it's a huge task to follow those
individuals but i look forward to the
challenge ahead
and i look forward to working with
junior minister
in terms of that role as well gary
meddling and i would like him to say a
few words
thanks paul i first want to thank our
party leader edwin
and to paula as well obviously it's a
great honor for me to take up
the position of junior minister and to
support our incoming
first minister i served in this role
briefly for a short time
when edwin took a step back for a period
i got my feet under the table and i've
seen the difference that we can make
within that office so very much look
forward to taking up the role
obviously as a voice for the north west
i think it is important and then we
recognize that we deliver for all of
northern ireland as well
i think we have a very strong team and i
look forward to getting to work
over the coming weeks i want to take
this opportunity as well just to thank
uh
gordon lyons mla for the fantastic work
that he has done
and obviously the outgoing first
minister erin foster as well
thank you